facing suarez making his 10th start on
the season
ranger is 6-4 an era of 1.50 and the
orioles now have runners on first and
third with one man down here in the
first and pedro severino is going to be
the hitter
savarino scorches one to center field a
base hit
austin hayes will score
and the orioles are three for four in
the first hitting against ranger suarez
in his 150 era one nothing on the
severino single
orioles trying to add more with ryan
mckenna in the five spot today
and mckenna very patient hitter knocks
the first one in a right let's see what
santander does to third base waved home
he is safe
throw into second mckenna will head back
to first d.d gregorius wants to hang on
to this with severino at third it's an
rbi single for ryan mckenna and the
orioles aggressive in the first inning
four for five with a couple runs in well
john means kind of happy that they got
him a couple of runs
and rio mucho floats a change up off the
end of the bat to hayes three fly-outs
in a scoreless first inning for john
means the orioles lead after one in
philadelphia that puts two on just one
out and mountain castles coming up
bouncer over to third galvest has got it
to second for one sigourna first in time
that is a huge double play
for ranger suarez and the phils
four three andrew mccutchen leads it off
lines one back through the middle of
base hit
a baby first hit of the night for the
phils
they've got the base runner to lead off
this second inning
thomas takes a high fastball out to
right santander into foul territory and
john means will get to start the third
inning against his opposing pitcher
[Music]
well that's an inexperienced first
baseman also
who was starting to go after the ball
and then ranger well ranger was trying
to be as cool as a cat
i don't know if the first base umpire
dan bellino said he was out of the
baseline or if ranger tagged him
watch the the wave of the hands from dan
bellino
no no he said he tagged him he got him
and then he went out of the baseline
all right so it's either way he
should be two outs right
well john means
has been very very good tonight he has
walked one he has allowed one hit
rookie first baseman veerling it's a
change-up on the ground
and pat valenka throws him
out pitch
and there's a line drive into the
overshift and shallow right for lake is
there he throws onto first
sets gregory is down
it's a shortstop
get up there you go martin throws at the
orioles old shortstop galvez with an
assist from mount castle 5-1 hit innings
in the books for john maines
last philly to reach was mccutchen with
a single leading off the second and
herrera grounds his 2-2 into right field
that breaks up
the run of 13 in a row retired and that
will bring chigurh to the plate
as a one-out tying run
segura into center field long run
mckenna this will hang up there for
route number two
and now bryce harper will bat in this
bottom of the six representing the time
run
struck out harper in the fourth
and he strikes him out to end the sixth
a 2-2 curveball to get
the national league mvp front-runner
john means who's throwing 91 pitches is
going to stand at the plate here let's
see if he does anything else at it john
means the last orioles pitcher to get a
hit back in 2019
july 24th
this ball into center field drifting
back herrera and that's over his head
off the wall
john means in the second with a double
over the head of herrera and they're
losing their minds in the oriole dugout
swing away johnny
the fills will bring mccutchen to the
plate as the tying run
popped it up got away with a high curve
ball and you can just put his head down
body language tells you so much
rails have only turned seven double
plays behind means this year fly ball
pitcher and a ground ball here valaka
gets to it and his throw not caught by
martin at second
the lake is sprawled out
fielded the ball but couldn't get it on
the base to martin who
could not catch the throw and the
phillies have two on
on the ground mount castle will spin go
to second
and get a force out there confident play
by ryan three to six
real muto to third gregorius to first
two down in the innings up to the
bullpen cole salsa will come in the
orioles best reliever in 2021 and galvez
takes him out to right field but
santander is there and that's the end of
the seventh inning
phillies will lean back onto the bullpen
they got a scoreless inning from sam
coonrod and now it's archie bradley
fly ball right field not deep
playable for harper
is able to make the catch for the first
down here in the eighth inning
drop ball to first
it dearly has it
swinging a foul tip
but
your staff is keeping you within reach
you get a one two three inning and then
harper's a pretty harmless batter in the
ninth
well jam shot to third gutierrez will
play it with the glove in time he got
herrera barely
but we've just seen this this is
pretty much every night
nice play by mount castle because he's
big and rangy he's got long arms snap
throw certainly not routine but he makes
it look that way
there you go
and on the 2-2 salsa pops him up to
first and bryce harper will have to wait
for the ninth the one two three eighth
inning for silser
you know
you get this oh we
went five out of seven we'll be good wow
looking very wow what a play
he covered a lot of grounds
and matt bierling's able to track that
one down for the first down here in the
ninth inning
wells on four days rest today hoping
that'll be a good physical and mental
break for him after the couple of blown
saves cedric mullins has been double
switched into the game in for mckenna so
mullins would lead off the 10th inning
hopefully that won't have to happen
tyler wells to bryce harper in a first
pitch fly ball
mullins may be tested here into the game
up to the wall he makes the catch
401 feet to dead center and harper hit
it about 400.9
and rio muto chases ball four again but
he hits it well but right at santondar
at the wall
tyler wells the year of living
dangerously but he's got two outs in the
ninth
two down for mccutchen
first pitch swing and andrew pops it up
severito is there
mask aside
ball signature
eventually
oh
pedro severino just to make it a little
more fun
the eventual squeeze and the orioles
shut out the phillies